it turns out
we as individuals are pretty junk at
doing most things by ourselves
uh we're not you know we're not that
smart to solve all the problems by
ourselves we're not that strong to lift
all the heavy weights by ourselves
and as social animals we're just better
in groups that's what we are and so
anybody who thinks they can manage this
thing called life or career or work
alone
um it's it's a fool's errand
and at the end of the day the one of the
most difficult things one of the most
difficult lessons for any of us to have
to learn but it's also the most
rewarding is simply to say the words i
don't know or i need help
or will you help me and it turns out
we're all surrounded by people who want
to help us they don't because they don't
think we need it and turns out as soon
as we're willing to ask
it's amazing that the army of people who
are right by our side